arnaud on vous présente plus est le fils
de serge et béate klarsfeld avocat
international
parallèlement vous a vu sur canal + en
émission qui s'appelait citoyens qu'à
romancier sportif
tombeur on peut le dire aussi et
secrétaire général de la licra à paris
très longtemps il ya très longtemps
il ya très longtemps alors je pense que
vous connaissez le livre de ménard la
censure des bien pensants on va
commencer avec la vente d'objets
antisémites sur internet sur yahoo
donc des insignes nazis des dagueys 16
des bonbonnes de zyklon b sont
accessibles en france et il ya eu une
plainte de la licra et de l'union des
étudiants juifs de france pour que ça
soit interdite en france la vente de ces
objets qui est autorisé aux états unis
centre de yahoo
c'était interdit sous prétexte c'est
compréhensible que c'est une offense à
la mémoire collective voilà donc la
justice a demandé un filtrage mais les
avocats de yahoo en californie ont fait
appel et un juge américain a déclaré que
la loi française ne veut pas assez
appliqué car le siège de yahoo justement
comme je le dis et aux usa voilà ici à
la loi qui dit voilà ce que vous pouvez
faire vous pouvez pas faire aux etats
unis c'est pas la loi qui décide de sa
la constitution peut-être parce qu'on
n'est pas dans les mêmes pays
c'est un pays libéral où on dit toutes
les opinions peuvent s'exprimer et on
fait confiance aux gens au caractère
adultes des gens pour décider entre ce
qui est raisonnable ce qui est absurde
ce qui peut être choquant ce qui peut
être bouleversant pour certains et
puisqu'il n'est pas évidemment
évidemment que c'est monstrueux d'aller
acheter un certain nombre d'objets du
troisième reich
évidemment que les gens qui font ça ils
sont évidemment des traqués dans leur
tête mais je ne crois pas on ne crois
pas qu'avec l'interdiction frappant
c'est les choses c'est ça le pari
le pari c'est dire il y en a marre de
systématiquement faire appel à l'état
on peut faire confiance aux gens on peut
paris
et si des gens d idée stupide on essaie
de les convaincre qu'ils ont des idées
stupides
il a enfin sur yahoo par exemple ils
vendent pas de drogue ils vendent pas de
livres pédophiles sont yahoo
donc en france et en amérique ont donc
est-ce qu'on peut pas considérer que dès
que des bonbonnes de zyklon b c'est
quand même quelque chose le zyklon b il
faut dire à nos amis jeunes
téléspectateurs c'était quand même le
gaz qu'on mettait dans les chambres à
gaz donc quand même y'a des gens qui
achètent ça est ce que finalement ça
peut pas être considéré comme un ouvrage
pédophiles ou comme de la drogue et être
interdite sur yahoo une fois pour toutes
non je crois que c'est pas la même chose
je crois que c'est pas la même chose
pourquoi c'est choquant c'est choquant
pour ce que ça représente
vendre du zyklon b c'est bien ça fait du
saf est due cette cause de la du chagrin
et de la peine à ceux qui ont vécu qui
ont perdu leurs parents et peut-être on
vendra du zyklon b dans 50 ans dans 60
ans quand ceux qui auront perdu leurs
parents
et bien ne seront plus là et quand le la
tragédie de la shoah sera sorti des des
coeurs pour devenir l'histoire mais
jusqu'à là cela cause du tort à ceux qui
ont souffert et qui souffre encore de
de ça mais est ce que vous vous
mobilisez quant à moscou on en vend
aujourd'hui les signes de l'armée rouge
le communisme dans le monde ses 80
millions de morts on sait bien que pour
lutter contre le communisme pour
recruter et je suis d'accord avec vous
contre le retour de toutes ces
monstruosités
il faut lutter mais sûrement pas par
l'interdiction on passe au cas des
révisionnistes auquel un chapitre de
votre livre est consacré robert ménard
donc le plus connu des révisionnistes et
faurisson
robert faurisson alors eux ils nient
l'existence des chambres à gaz dans les
camps d'extermination nazis
alors vous vous dites ils ont raison ils
sont l'objet ces gens là d'une véritable
chasse aux sorcières
ils sont victimes de la police de la
pensée ils sont victime d'un
détournement du droit à cause de la loi
gayssot
c'est à dire que des gens qui affirment
des choses que l'on s'est contredite par
tout ce que l'on sait sur la solution
finale
finalement vous dites il arrive à faire
passer grâce à la loi gayssot pour des
victimes de l'intolérance et vous dit
cette loi gayssot
c'est une ânerie c'est une loi inique je
précise tout de suite que je ne partage
en rien évidemment le point de vue des
révisionnistes ce qu'il dit ce sont des
absurdités et je le redis ici simplement
ce que nous disons c'est deux choses
d'une part ce sont des absurdités
mais en ayant mis sur pied une noix
exprès pour interdire ils sont moins
d'une dizaine
on leur a fait la plus belle publicité
qu'on pouvait leur faire d'une part
d'autre part ça reste des idées
monstrueuse choquant blessantes vous
avez raison mais des idées des idées
chose parce que attendait ses 5500
cressonnière seconde c'est qu'on se
laisse ses complices et complexes ont
pas dit ce matériau est ce qu'on peut
parler à demi nue alors c'est ce que
vous pouvez faire mais ce que je peux
parler vous me laissez parler ce ne sont
pas des c'est faux ce sont des ordures
antisémite qui savent très bien que les
choses ont eu lieu qui savent très bien
que les juifs ont été exterminés et qui
pour faire passer leur haine antisémite
et bien disent les juifs n'ont jamais
été tués finalement quand vous vous
faite insulter vous avez le droit de
demander des dommages et intérêts quand
vous fait injurier vous
voit on dévoile votre vie privée vous
avez le droit de demander des dommages
et intérêts quand vous au quand on dit
que quelqu'un était coupable de faits de
collaboration alors que ça a été
amnistié il a le droit de demander de
dommages et intérêts et ont dit un tout
un peuple
vous volez 6 millions de morts n'ont
jamais existé et ceux qui ont perdu
leurs parents qui sont traité d'escroc
parce qu'ils ont touché des réparations
eux ils ont aucun droit
c'est hier vous vous parler en termes
intellectuels ou en termes comme ça sans
prendre en considération la souffrance
des gens quand les derniers survivants
ceux qui auront perdu leurs parents
et bien cela seront morts et bien à ce
moment là la loi est bien le sort a
abrogé parce qu'elle n'aura plus de
raison d'être
mais maintenant si on dit vous en faites
vous êtes un sale escroc juif qui a
touché des réparations alors que alors
que l'on a une seconde alors que votre
pain alors que votre mère est mort c'est
une insulte alors je vois pas pourquoi
ce que ceux qui ont dévoile la vie
prévue le droit de toucher des
réparations et saute on dit vous êtes un
escroc et vos parents le sont pas morts
n'ont aucun droit
et bien cette loi sera abrogée voilà fil
du temps quant à aujourd'hui quand on
dit par exemple si quelqu'un dit la
saint-barthélemy n'ai jamais eu lieu
bon bah poursuivi mais qui souffre
aujourd'hui qui a perdu ses parents de
lors de la saint barthélemy personne
quelqu'un perdu son arrière arrière
arrière arrière arrière grand père donc
les souffrances les plus vivaces
il n'y a plus de gens qui en comprend
compromettre leur intérêt pour vous
robert ménard toutes les idées même les
plus odieuses doivent pouvoir s'exprimer
premier point et deuxième point aucune
idée évidemment le de pouvoir échapper à
la critique à la dérision et à la
caricature voilà donc vous êtes partisan
d'un absolu de la liberté
mais est ce que pour la liberté comme
pour le reste est ce que l'absolu n'est
pas inatteignable et très dangereux n'en
ont dit deux choses on dit d'une part il
ya deux limites à la liberté
d'expression a ses les appels à la
violence si je dis il faut tuer monsieur
d'ormesson
évidemment c'est plus de l'ordre de
l'idée mais ces dames c'est une
tentative de meurtre une incitation ou
pas vous parce que vous achèterez à côté
de moi
le deuxième point c'est l'insulté
personnelle vous avez le droit de vous
défendre
à partir de là on doit pouvoir débat je
me méfie on se méfiait qu'emmanuel de
quelque chose de simple c'est ce qu'ils
veulent penser à notre place on vit on
sort d'un siècle pour cent celle ci à
gombe où il ya des gens qui ne sont pas
une joue pas une insulte ya touché à une
jambe qui file à zulte de je vais penser
à votre place
ces pasteurs c'est pas une insulte de
dire à des gens qui ont perdu leur père
mère ou leur père leur père en fait vous
n'avez perdu personne
vous êtes un escroc résultat si c'est
une insulte alors ce doit être non
pourquoi non bonjour si cet argent car
oui si je vous dis vous est une ordure
et 1p 2010 par vous pourrez trier mais à
moi vous voulez dans ce cas là vous le
dis pourquoi pas briller pour vous le
dites à l'ensemble d'une pac et du
catégorie rap au passage et robert
excusez moi mais ce que dit arno klasen
c'est finalement dire les chambres à gaz
il y avait des camps de concentration
mais ce n était pas des camps
d'extermination ski le discours des des
révisionnistes absolue ce qui dit
finalement c'est une insulte aux gens
qui sont morts je vous prends un autre
exemple il ya eu je le disais à peu près
80 millions de morts du fait des
communistes pendant des années il ya un
certain nombre de gens ici des grands
responsables politiques qui ont lié le
goulag
c'était une insulte aux victimes du
goulag est ce qu'un d'entre vous c'est
dit on va poursuivre ce marché on va
poursuivre les communistes à l'époque
parce que il est ici sauce est
attentatoire à la mémoire des victimes
évidemment pas les gens qui disent il
n'y a pas eu d'extermination des juifs
comme on le sait maintenant
évidemment c'est insultant évidemment il
faut le combattre
mais évidemment pas devant les prétoires
évidemment pas devant les pressions
c'est ce qu'on va pas devant les
prétoires c'est ce combat par les
travaux universités xi heures quand
giscard d'estaing disait y avait cent
mille juifs qui ont été déportés de
france mon père a montré qu'ils avaient
76 mille juifs qui ont été déportés de
france et non pas 100 milles
quand raul hilberg dix le nombre de
juifs y ont été exterminés plutôt de
l'ordre de 5 millions et où que 6
millions personne ne pense à l'accuser
de ré
sionisme bon genre vous pensez qu'il
faut abolir la loi gayssot nom alors je
pense que dans l'idéal évidemment je
partage absolument votre opinion dans
l'idéal c'est la liberté totale
mais c'est vrai que en pratique nous
avons tous une espèce de dette en europe
à l'égard de la chaux sacs gonflables
je vous prends un autre exemple parce
que dans dieu merci dans ce livre on
parle pas que derrière ce trio 10 ans et
non non non non on parle d'autres gens
sur le racisme
le racing je ne suis pas non plus
raciste est-ce que la meilleure façon de
combattre le racing était le monde c'est
encore eddie izzard il ya tellement il
ya tellement de cause dans le monde je
peux ya des enfants qui meurent de faim
il reste six mille rené hauss et rose
quelques milliers de tigre géant on tue
des gens ici à droite et à gauche c'est
ce que vous venez dire c'est oui il faut
que les révisionnistes où il faut que
les racistes puisse s'exprimer
je m'en balance les harrachis s'est
arrimé ça s'est passé à nardo ont nagé
pas vraiment besoin de vos leçons pour
défendre la liberté ailleurs et pas
seulement dans des salons s'il vous
plaît civils selon la dgt
selon la deuxième chaîne quels sont vos
fins quels sont vos au fait qu'est ce
que c'est c'est la maison qu'est le
salon c'est à moi que vous dites ça
louineau exactement ça vous dit de faire
casser la gueule
moi j'ai reçu des bombes moi j'étais ici
moi j étais là quels sont vos faits vous
en voulez vous on vous attend sur le
show pour défendre la liberté d'après
tout ça sauf à ça quels sont vos risques
personnels que vous avez pris attendez
moi je n'étale pas ici mais risquent
bien évidemment canadien n'a pas venant
de vous faites quoi rigoler ce que je
veux c'est me titillait ça c'est ce qui
s'appelle normalement mais de la
crétinerie a plu au point un logiciel
c'est ça c'est ça c'est de la tolérance
c'est ça c'est vraiment quelle tolérance
robert encore un mot en eau klarsfeld un
plaidoyer pour la tolérance maintenant
tolérant mais je suis pas tous les rangs
avec les racistes ni raciste ni négation
de refaire le coup ce que vous faisiez
c'est celle des racistes et je vous
explique ça je vous dire non on défend à
longueur de temps je défends à longueur
de temps des gens qui dans leur pays
sont ans de prison sont en prison pour
leurs idées ça ça existe bien alors tant
qu on vous tient à nos classes fel de
quand guy sorman kit anti sioniste il
est contre l'existence de l'état juif
quand il dit israël est un accident
historique et il se rappelle un petit
peu ce que colombani rapporté dans son
livre il disait qu un jour colombani il
dînait à l'elysée alors il dit pas qui a
dit ça mais qu' on a parlé au sujet
d'israël analyser ce soir là de
parenthèse historique et lui sorman ils
parlent d'accidents historique qui dit
qu' israël voilà c'est arrivé en 48 puis
que ça c'est sera que ce serait si bas
pour l'éternité
vous réagissez comme ans quand vous
voyez un c pour ca qu arafat à papa pas
voulu de faire faire la paix avec avec
barak
c'est parce qu'ils croient que encore qu
israël peut peut disparaître et que
beaucoup d'européens le croire encore
encore encore et que si finalement les
fans se dit il vaut mieux ne pas rentrer
dans l'histoire comme celui qui a fait
la paix avec avec les israéliens et
si l'état croisés a disparu et bien
israël peut disparaître quelqu'un qui se
place dans une perspective historique
mais il n'y a pas eu il n'y a pas eu
d'israël pendant pendant
ddd siècle pendant 2000 ans est bien ici
israël peut disparaître et peut-être pas
mal de diplomate européen ou au quai
d'orsay ont à peu près la même approche
que l'ancien porte parole du quai
d'orsay qui était ambassadeur de france
à londres qui a dit qu'il aurait été un
petit pays en mer de quillan qui emmerde
et le monde et ils disent finalement va
avec sans état d'israël le monde serait
plus un peu plus ce serait plus facile
mais enfin les si les juifs n'ai pas
d'état et bien il est juif se ferait
persécutés aussi ailleurs dans le monde
et israël remparts à l'antisémitisme
aussi dans le monde et s'y est pas
israël sans doute que les négationnistes
sans doute que les juifs s'organiserait
pour éliminer tout simplement les
négationnistes parce qu'après que après
que six millions de juifs étaient des
tués est bien les ennemis du peuple juif
doivent être prêts doivent être
combattus c'est la leçon car tout le
monde est d'accord là dessus
non non non non recevoir la flotte
on se méfie maintenant ce qui est
insupportable
m klarsfeld s'est pas du tout ce que
vous dites moi je partage pas votre
point de vue sur tout mais quand vous
dites qu arafat et un sinistre
personnage je suis absolument d'accord
on voit ce qu'il fait à son propre
peuple c'est un régime corrompu
népotique il n'a jamais un mot pour
condamner un vrai mot pour condamner les
attentes les attentats kamikazes tout ça
vous avez raison mais une fois qu'on a
dit ça on a le droit aussi
m klarsfeld de critiquer monsieur sharon
sans être pour autant taxés ni d'
antisémite ni de quelqu'un contre eux et
pas les siens et moi je ne jette pas de
l'aussonnelle figure bien merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un
peu de bleu